cbs news medical contributor dr david
agus joins us now david good morning
as you just heard ben say uh the
president's doctor said he may not be
entirely out of the woods dr fauci said
there could be a reversal
in the next few days how critical are
these next few days for the president
well he's still on dexamethasone so
dexamethasone
decadron this steroid we use until lungs
improve so obviously his lungs aren't
improved because he's still on that
medicine
and i have seen cases where you get
continually improvement from this point
but i've also seen cases where there's a
lull
and then things get worse and that's
what we're worried about
you know he feels well you take off the
decadron the steroids
he's not going to feel well and there
will be a crash and that energy we're
seeing
now will go away what do you think is
the significance of the
doctor not wanting to show the
president's lung scans
well saying well it's hipaa which is the
patient privacy act
really is inappropriate because the pa
president the patient can say
it's okay for you to tell people about
la lang so what he's saying is the
president doesn't want people to know
about that lung scan it's critical that
we know whether there's 10 percent
involved 50 percent evolved 80 percent
evolved to the lungs
whatever that number is tells us how
critical his disease is and likely what
his course will be
david we also still don't have an answer
on when the president last
tested negative why is that information
so important well it's important because
it will say who he was exposed to
i mean who was exposed to him so it's
about other people it's about caring for
everybody who when you were positive
or could have been positive and you had
intimate reactions
interactions with somebody they need to
be quarantined and tested that's how we
contact race
and that's how we stop the spread of the
virus that is
critical so other people don't get a
fight infected with this virus
so david why do you let someone out of
the hospital who
all the experts say is not out of the
woods yet with so many uncertainties i
realize the white house has top of the
notch
facilities but it's still not a medical
center
so on friday when this all began he
didn't really have a team
a team was built and so now he was
transferred so i don't think it is a
discharge as much as a transfer okay to
the white house where those same doctors
will manage his care
and if something goes wrong if he gets
worse he has trouble breathing they
could take him down to the icu unit
and i've seen it it is state of the art
they can put him on a ventilator and
transport him within minutes
literally back to walter reed so i i
don't think that part's unsafe
i think it's uh obviously he's not out
of the woods and i think that's critical
but we're going to continue to follow
him in the white house
yeah the president raised a lot of
eyebrows and i think hurt a lot of
people's feelings
especially when you think that 210 000
people have died
when he says listen i feel really good
don't let it dominate your life don't
let it take you
i kept thinking about how the families
that are still grieving would hear those
words
what did you think when you heard them
well i thought about 210 000 people
would love to have a team of 10 doctors
dedicated to them would love to have
access to medicines that aren't yet fda
approved and
me as a scientist as a doctor i think
there's real hope with these medicines
um they would have loved access to those
medicines when they were sick
and so it's not necessarily genuine to
say my story is your story when the
president talks about
people with covet 19. yeah he plans to
participate in the next debate i think
it's like
nine days away is that realistic or is
it too hard to say right now
well let's see what happens when the
decks of methazone has stopped i've seen
you know patients who have a dramatic
drop in their energy the day after you
know i had a patient two months ago
i put him on steroids that next day he
called a contractor to build an
underground bowling alley at his house
several days later we took him off sarah
she goes
i hate bowling and i have no money why
would i do such a thing
that's the steroids and so we'll see
what happens when those steroids stop
and when the doctors think he is not
infectious anymore
all right that's by the story that's
kind of a funny story
i hate bowling okay thank you david
higgins thank you very much i hope they
didn't start construction
i think there's already a bowling alley
in the white house